bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors la
cour constitutionnelle doit encore
valider les résultats de cette
présidentielle on vient de le dire le
candidat de l'opposition revendique sa
victoire il dénonce des fraudes peut-on
s'attendre à un retournement situation
selon vous à mon avis nous c'est un
processus de validation qui doit
continuer
peut-être la surprise viendra de l'armée
mais en tout cas pour le moment elle
regarde l arbitre de loin mais en tout
cas la situation aujourd'hui c'est que
ben azzouz me est dans cette position de
président élu
la validation est en cours et le pays on
le voit il ya des troubles mais mais je
pense dans la tradition nigériane il ya
pas de la contestation n'est pas dans
les chromosomes de de ce peuple mais me
renseigne jamais le poids de la crise le
malaise le mal-être le terrorisme qui a
enfermé le pays dont certaine morosité
dans la crise économique
et tout cela peut il donc évidemment
joué pour les semaines à venir
ahmad base aussi si sa victoire est
confirmée va succéder au président
sortant mamadou issoufou qui a qui a
donc exercé trois mandats à la tête du
niger c'est un changement dans la
continuité puisqu'on sait que mohamed
bazoum c'est le dauphin justement d'un
ils se font actuellement des cantons
auront conclu l'homme c'est un homme qui
a d'abord une intelligence remarquable
illzach et 2006
de par ses fonctions à l'intérieur de
deux des processus
[Musique]
gouvernementaux il a pu gagnerie joue un
savoir-faire du terrain il a des
qualités personnelles de canalys donc si
un homme courant des années le ministère
de l'intérieur puis à sion nigérienne ni
qu'aujourd'hui pour le cas présent si le
ciel est un terrorisme qui se généralise
un peu partout l'univers est qu un hic
les lui il connaît ça terrienne là une
vision sécuritaire de la situation
autant voilées jouent pas niger c'était
un million deux cent mille kilomètres et
qu'un effet entouré de cette nuit avec
deux mois le source de menace mais
vraiment forte
le boko haram d'un côté et obtient 10 au
niveau 2 du sahel de notre site un pays
qui une sous pression en permanence
d'ailleurs quand on le voit le niger
niamey qui lit à côté de papa loin de
cao minh aka lit dans ce triangle
évidemment avec la libye dans le chaos
il ne s'en sent que c'est un pays qui
s'épuise dans cette lutte contre le
terrorisme
le budget et les filles est estimé à
entre 18% et 20% du pib
c'est aussi d'érable dans le budget de
l'état
si tapie sous la menace permanente que
l'expérience de bazoum valider une fois
validée dans cette sélection par les
instances ainsi si ce n'est que les
constitutionnels là qu'il a beaucoup
beaucoup de choses athlètes apporte la
paix intérieure au niger il est issu
d'une minorité
la minorité arabe mais il doit prouver
aussi
ce sont son côté et qui est équilibrée
par rapport aux autres écrit un pays de
50 lits et c'est possible même si il ya
un 4 5/10 le prix domine de ce ppp x9
voilà un peu la situation il ya
énormément de choses à amener rival et
les sur les prochaines années
donc les défis sont énormes
merci beaucoup en tout cas échéant mme
benyaich d'avoir répondre à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
rédacteur en chef du magazine new
african african business en français